all right you internet weirdos it's
friday and that means it's time for
another roundtable extravaganza i'm your
host dave rubin this is the reuben
report and joining me today
is an author a mathematician a
professional troublemaker and a guy who
maybe is still suspended from twitter
we'll find out in just a moment james
lindsey
a writer a speaker and a mad mama over
in crazy california alicia krauss an
editor-in-chief of the post-millennial a
place of journalism without air quotes
libby emmons james alicia libby welcome
back to the reuben report hi
hey thanks
all right good to see you crazy kids uh
we're gonna kind of recap the week and
sort of woke lunacy uh but before we do
anything i woke up this morning having
my coffee i opened the twitter i know
nothing good could possibly be happening
and i see that my mild-mannered friend
james lindsey has been suspended
by twitter so we're going to start with
that let me just talk to you guys about
real estate agents i trust real quick
and then we will get to it you guys know
that buying or selling a home is already
one of the most stressful things you can
do and it can be 10 times worse if
you're not working with the right agent
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
founded by my buddy glenn beck they work
with only the best agents in every
market they do their homework talking to
every agent before inviting them to join
their network and here's a big one they
only work with full-time pros no
part-time or inexperienced agents their
team makes the introduction and then
follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records they're the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
including the free state of florida just
go to real estate agents itrust.com
today give them some info they'll reach
out to you and then you will live
happily ever after okay let's get to it
first off we've got a headline here from
the daily caller this is a couple days
ago because you know these left wing
woke progressive whatever the hell you
want to call them at this point these
activists are uh they're always pushing
for the rest of us to be censored so
here's a headline from the daily caller
a few days ago left left-wing activists
urge big tech to censor
anti-pedophile
smear now the anti-pedophile smear that
they're referring to is this meme of ok
groomers that's been going around the
internet and this is where people are
calling out all of these sort of gender
queer teachers who want to talk to other
people's children about sexuality and
not report it back to the parents
etc etc you guys get all that well then
uh this uh this is a woman i believe ari
drennon is a woman although i'm not a
biologist
from media matters she's the
lgbtq program director over at media
matters uh she wrote she tweeted this
daily caller we aren't
anti-lgbtq we're anti-pedophile
uh also the daily caller uses a generic
picture of young people holding pride
flags in the article and then here's
where the story hit home james lindsay
tweeted back okay groomer and he was
quickly swiftly dealt with by the
twitter lords he was suspended james uh
you're a mean dude huh you're you just
don't want to play by their rules and
you want to uh you know go on the attack
against people who want to talk to other
people's kids about sex what's the deal
with you
yeah i don't like that when when they
talk to other people's kids about sex
and our mortal enemies are clown trooper
whatever we have over at media matters
or got sick of the little trend i
started i don't know if you knew dave i
started the okay groomer thing back in
october i think i have the first okay
was that you you were actually like the
legit first okay groomer person
i am the first okay groomer that's right
and wow and then i did i did a series of
podcasts i've titled groomer schools
there are four of them the most recent
one i did just a few weeks ago released
a few weeks ago where i read through a
paper talking about drag queen story
hour and i'm not okay with drag queen
story hour i'm not okay with groomers
i'm not okay with whether this is sexual
grooming or ideological cult grooming um
and so i called this out and media
matters couldn't handle this after a
number of months i didn't know
apparently they changed the rule on
twitter back in february without telling
anybody that they've made this an
explicit rule that you can't call
protected classes of people whom i
assume they mean are the t's and the q's
because most lbs and g's are against
the uh grooming thing
so you can't call a t or a q within the
alphabet people and maybe some of the
probably most of the pluses if i had to
guess uh you can't call those people
groomers on twitter as they'll mass
report you and then
they'll knock you off and put something
about it in your wikipedia entry
can we call people that support the
groomers groomers i mean i would argue
that people like the biden
administration aoc nancy pelosi at all
are supporting grooming of my children
so
well i get kicked off on twitter if i
call them out for that it's just it's
unbelievable the social media overlords
and what they do and do not allow us to
say
libby do you have a better phrase do you
have a better phrase libby for this i
was on a a radio show i'm not even going
to call the guy out because he's he's a
friendly to most of us i think nice
enough guy but he was asking me a couple
weeks ago about the okay groomer thing
and he said dave do you think it's over
the top and i had said i said to him you
know i've never said it on my show
actually people you know there's a
internet culture and what i do here okay
fine i said but do you have a better
phrase for a group of people who want to
talk to other people's children
six-year-olds about sex and gender and
hide it from their parents you have a
better phrase for it and without
blinking he goes uh what about
indoctrinator and i thought well is that
better than groomer is that worse than
groomer like that's the level of sort of
stupidity that we're dealing with libby
you got a better word than groomer for
these people you know i i don't
necessarily back in april during the
trans day of visibility when president
biden went on twitter and said to
american parents that it was their
responsibility to affirm their kids we
called him the groomer in chief and i do
think that the fact that these activists
are offended by the term
groomer and aligning that term with
themselves is such an insane self-owned
do they not realize that by saying that
lgbtq people uh that's saying using the
term groomer for activists in the lgbtq
movement
um
saying that that's offensive to them is
actually kind of insane and shows that
uh
they must relate to it in some way i
don't see what you can call a third
grade teacher who tells her students to
use all the pronouns and then hides it
from parents hides it from the
administration says that they're this
very safe space for all of this um
indoctrinators grooming indoctrinators
uh
sex advocates for kids i don't know like
i think groomer is actually pretty apt
and this ban actually reminds me
six-year-old
yeah it reminds me of when megan murphy
was banned i think in 2018 for saying
yeah him
yeah him
you know really this is what we get
banned for it's just it's so obvious
that this is an agenda-driven
um
you know batch of lies that's being
right and let's see
also let's not forget i mean jordan
peterson is now officially suspended
from twitter because he called ellen
page elliott page i got suspended for
literally referencing the fact that
jordan peterson was suspended i'm still
unclear who was the actress that was in
x-men was that an actor named elliot
page or a woman named ellen page it
doesn't matter but uh alicia alicia you
have you have young kids you have young
kids
school age kids that are i know through
you are not getting any of this nonsense
but what are your what are your friends
saying what are the other mad mamas
saying about this stuff when they're
getting their kids back from school you
know it's so fascinating of course now
in southern california i've been talking
with moms in la county and now san diego
county who are going um backwards in
ways i cannot use appropriate words for
online because they're wanting to
re-mask our children and uh vax them up
and all this stuff on top of this and
even my most left-leaning friends are
like yeah i don't want my three-year-old
to go to an art camp in the summertime
and then come back with a sticker that
says his pronouns on it right like they
don't understand that they think that
they are just a boy and they're a girl
because those are the two sexes that
there are and i've been saying it in my
yaf speeches for a really long time i
just went to my babies three year i
can't believe she's three her three-year
wellness check and our pediatrician at
every two year and every three year
wellness because it is a way of
determining their mental and educational
state and whether they are aware of
reality versus pretend she does the same
thing with disney characters can you be
ariel can you be the little mermaid yes
or no and this is something that the
left is infringing on and being overly
radical and there are a lot of mad mamas
even in blue states that are like you
know i'm not okay with it but sometimes
as you know it's they're very nimby it's
not in their backyard so if they can
tell you that it's a good idea and they
can act like they pretend to support
this and you know on the socials and at
the cocktail parties and the dinner
parties then fine but really in their
own homes and behind the scenes they're
doing everything that they can to make
sure that their children are not the
ones that are being groomed hey james to
alicia's point there you mentioned a
moment ago a sort of distinction between
whether they're grooming them for sort
of sexual purposes or for more
ideological purposes i i sense what you
mean is just like sort of break down a
three-year-old or a six-year-old's
ability to have any sense of what
reality is
my gut feeling is it's more on the
latter i don't think this is necessarily
all about molesting these kids i i
obviously at some level it is but i
think it's more of the latter that you
just break their ability to have any
sense of what's real at six and then why
wouldn't they buy into all of the rest
of the ways that you want to control
them do you think it's more of the
latter actually
overwhelmingly yeah they're i mean to
use a leftist word they're
co-constituted if you break down kids
sense of reality and you give them the
sense of trust and you're talking to
them about sexual topics already there
will be some sexual exploitation and
predation that happens but this is
overwhelmingly ideological or cult
grooming
another term since we were talking about
that you could use thought reform which
is the term that the chinese used for
their their prisons this is a very
maoist program and the idea is in fact
that why are they doing this this
grooming thing why are they doing this
cult indoctrination this thought reform
thing and it is for three primary
purposes i told uh on on ali beth
stuckey our friend ali's podcast the
other day i said there are three main
reasons one is they want to destabilize
the kid it's not going to be hard to get
these kids to believe whatever you need
them to believe to flip out about
climate change if you can convince them
that they aren't a boy or aren't a girl
or that they don't know you know what
basic
sex is um that's not going to be
difficult so to destabilize the children
to make sure they don't know reality so
you can groom them into other political
points second is to sever them from
their families if they come home and say
all this weird stuff that's gonna you
know they're gonna say mom you don't
understand things are different now and
the third is to sever them from their
religion or any other cultural uh
grounding that gives them the ability to
make sense of their lives and have
continuity from one generation to the
next because if you're going to make
communists you have to install a whole
new society and you do that by building
it up in the children while discrediting
the adult world and i think that's the
ultimate agenda even if the people that
are doing it in the classroom don't even
realize they're playing a part in that
agenda
yeah david we've talked about it
sorry but real quick we've talked about
it on this show before um when i've been
on the friday roundup it it for the side
that said that they cared about mental
health and emotional well-being in
people's feelings for so long what james
is discussing and what he does a very
good job of discussing all the time
because he has the background and all
the data to go with it i see that is
leading to confusion and that is leading
to mental overload which is going to
negatively affect the emotions and the
development of america's children and
that is what is dangerous because not
only are you removing them from their
faith and their family but you're making
them question who they were are and who
they were born to be and that's like a
level of anxiety and depression that no
child should have pushed on them
i want to give you i want to give libby
the last word on this but james real
quick because you mentioned the religion
part and alicia just mentioned the
religion part of this um
you know you were you were sort of like
a very very outspoken atheist when i
knew you you know say five six seven
years ago when you were first on my show
do you find it odd that uh you're
suddenly being defended by all of these
religious people and have common cause
at this point with with those people in
the face of this thing
no because i think we both share
something much bigger in common which is
a recognition that reality exists and
reality is structured and that we can
comprehend it that's john
chapter one or
it begins with saying that the the logos
is the basis of reality that
word was god and the word was with god
and so um
no i think that we're actually on the
same page and i'll just add a real quick
point speaking of
what alicia just said the groomer
schools podcast i went through two
papers one of which is dry queen story
hour and one of which is equivalent
theory paper it's the the queer three
paper explicitly says that they want to
redo in terms of queer theory early
childhood development and early
childhood education because they want to
overcome the impediment that people are
saying this is developmentally
inappropriate for children so they want
to redefine what's developmentally
appropriate for young children and then
in the the groomer schools paper they
actually say directly to alicia's point
they say that they actually use the idea
that it's about encouraging
lgbtq empathy as a marketing strategy
but the real point is to teach children
to live queerly they say that explicitly
in the paper they end that paper by
saying that their goal is to leave a
trail of glitter in the carpet that will
never come out that's a direct quote and
so this what word do you use but groomer
for this yep yeah and for the record i
have never at least in my life met a gay
person that wanted anything to do with
any of this stuff i i really haven't i
think they've done so much damage to
just the average gay person who's out
there just trying to live their life who
was fighting for equality years ago i'm
actually going to let libby kick off
yeah this is as glittery as it gets my
friend look at this jacket i thought
this is the gayest thing i got here we
go um
the i'll let libby kick off the next one
here because it's a it's a good segue uh
the woke media is actually collapsing
right now i think enough people are
waking up to that reality that you're
referring to james we've got some info
here from cnbc about vice media this is
quite spectacular vice media the digital
media company once valued at 5.7 billion
that's billion with a b has hired
bankers to seek a sale according to
people familiar with the matter vice was
an early darling of the digital media
industry peaking in 2017 with the 450
million dollar investment from private
equity firm tpg that valued the company
at nearly 6 billion vice is considering
a sale as it seeks liquidity for
investors and to help pay back about a
billion dollars in debt
disney already rode off its 400 million
investment in 2019 with the expectation
that it would be worthless uh libby uh
you guys are doing some fine work over
at the post-millennial and i would say
it's in direct contrast to something
like vice that was sort of edgy and good
maybe six years ago and then went fully
woke and is now collapsing so uh pretty
sweet huh
yeah it's actually pretty fascinating to
watch this all go down uh vice isn't the
only one we saw cnn plus tank as well
meanwhile the post millennial is
growing and expanding um and i'm really
proud of the work that we're doing i
think the progressive media outlets are
bloated i think they're bloated on their
own ideology they're bloated with staff
and americans are tired of hearing from
their bettors how much they suck we
don't need this anymore you know we
don't need that these elites to come in
and start telling us that our views are
wrong that the things that we
speak are wrong that our political
perspectives are wrong that it's wrong
the way we're raising our kids that our
religion is wrong that we need to
restructure our entire world view to
match their activism which you know as
we just discussed has a lot of grooming
tendencies in it
and we don't need that americans don't
want it and they're they're speaking up
with their clicks and uh we're seeing
progressive media outlets just go down
they're also speaking up with their
eyeballs because msnbc or as i call it
the mental institution the televised
mental institution known as msnbc their
collapse and we've got this from the
daily wire
msnbc has chosen alex wagner to succeed
rachel maddow as host of its nightly
program marking a major change in
leftist media msnbc revealed the change
on monday regarding the 9 pm eastern
time slot on tuesday through friday
nights however matteo intends to
continue hosting the show on mondays
this is not a show where our hair is on
fire and we're yelling past each other
and we're creating these manufactured
moments of tension msnbc president
rashida jones told the new york times i
really want the takeaway from this show
to be a better understanding of what's
happening in the world maddow had
already stepped back from hosting after
a new deal with nbc universal according
to axios the host planned to leave her
position but decided to remain active as
the program's monday host the program
running since 2008 announced maddow's
plans to take hiatus in january so i
thought this was interesting because
rachel maddow is sort of a perfect
example of this whole thing you know she
seems like a nice person to some degree
or something she's a total media darling
but she gets every single story wrong
she has lied about everything every
whether it's brett kavanaugh or jessie
smallette or january 6 the list goes on
you guys get it and even msnbc is saying
boy enough of this and to make the story
even sweeter there are rumors they might
get rid of joy reid
so uh
alicia you're looking for a gig over on
msnbc
i know i was actually thinking i wonder
when uh this new host alex is gonna give
you and i ring to be on the show since
they want a taste of what's happening in
real america and have a dialogue and
discussion about it i would absolutely
love that give me a ring maybe i should
be working on my linkedin resume well
you know for the record alex
no go ahead well alex jones you uh it's
not alex alex jones that would be good
on msnbc actually but alex wagner
she used to have a daytime show on msnbc
and no one watched it and now they're
giving her the prime time slot that no
one's going to watch it's just i love i
need to find myself a gig where i can
fail up because the left does it so well
yeah you just have to be a lefty that's
that's how it works
james you're not going to get a call to
be on any of these programs you're
always willing to talk to these people
right i mean in the old days you were
able to get on some of these shows and
debate these people but the phone
doesn't ring anymore on that stuff right
no they've uh you mentioned alex jones i
understand that my reputation is roughly
hovering around his these days because
i'm saying a lot of the big c word that
nobody wants to talk about i talk about
things like esg and i say that this is a
communist revolution happening in the
united states and they think that that's
crazy um
i base it on having read their books and
connecting what i see in their books
which by the way nobody's done and then
connecting what i see in their books to
what i see happening around me and it's
like oh wow i found the road map
and then i just say those things and
that makes me insane so no they're not
they're not going to be too eager to
talk to me i don't think
do you think that the frogs are gay um i
thought there was something like that
kind is true or isn't it like no the
frogs make you gay the frogs themselves
are not gay they make but the water was
making the frogs gay i don't know i
thought they were putting the chemicals
in the water and the whole thing
libby you must be happy about this it's
sort of like the vice story it's like
good things are being built right
you know i think a lot of this too um is
just because so many of the narratives
that have been pushed by these media
outlets from
kovid to
russia collusion the hunter biden laptop
jessie smollette the persistent
insistence that um trans people are
suddenly the opposite sex just because
they say they are and so many of these
things having to then be walked back as
we have seen over and over again also
just shows that the first thing that
these outlets say are typically lies
that are aligned with the ruling
narrative
and the people in power that's what's
being upheld here they're not
questioning authority they're not
speaking truth to power they are
punching down the rest of us who are
looking for truth looking for facts
looking for reality and msnbc vice
magazine all of these places cnn
continued to deny that reality even
exists despite our being able to see it
with our own eyes so you're actually uh
i think it's right and just that they
are going down
and you're giving me a beautiful segue
to our next segment because speaking of
narrative over reality they constantly
tell us that everyone should come to
america and we should give them a lot of
stuff and we should have open borders
and everyone should share and apparently
the horror of our race is patriarchy but
they still want to come it's all very
bizarre but then reality hits them and
next thing you know in places like new
york city they're being overrun with
people that they cannot support here is
new york city mayor eric adams who i
have no doubt will soon be called a
racist by his leftist cohorts this is a
real burden on new yorkers as we're
trying to do the right thing
of we already as i stated we already
have an overburdened shelter system so
now we're talking about as you stated
food clothing school
this is going to impact our
of our schools because we do not turn
away individuals because they're
undocumented translation services
there's just a whole host of things that
this is going to produce and that's why
we need we need help
and getting this done and we need to
write coordination to make it happen
it's it's hilarious it's actually
hilarious that these people think if you
just let a gajillion people in you don't
check anything you give them services
that eventually it's not going to
collapse the system it's happening
everywhere also the dc mayor we covered
it earlier in the week is dealing with
the same thing her homeless shelters are
being overrun by illegals uh alicia you
live in l.a um how many homeless people
are you how many homeless people are you
sheltering right now because that's why
i left
um
not uh sheltering any of them we've got
a lot of gates and a moat and a few guns
and stuff like although i shouldn't be
saying that on air because the atf might
come knocking on my door but they'd have
to come through the two fences first
there you go
but uh it is actually heartbreaking that
i i say this all the time downtown la i
think has so much potential uh uh
just a week before that poor olympian
was clocked and almost lost sight we'll
get to that we'll get to that just a
second yeah a friend of mine was bitten
on the back of a head by a homeless
person this goes back to leftist
policies like in general though since
before you and i were born it's the not
in my backyard they will say that they
want these things to happen until they
actually start to happen and then they
realize oh wow government is not the end
all be all and we don't have the
resources to take care of these people
because guess what turns out the
government really sucks at taking care
of people they shouldn't be doing it
they should be minimizing their
involvement and letting the free market
speak for itself and we should be
protecting our borders because when we
protect our borders and we have an
immigration process that is legal and
that works it's beneficial not just to
current american citizens but the ones
that want to come here and when my buddy
ben shapiro and i used to do a morning
show we would say all the time we'd
actually rather trade uh probably a
couple million fellow millennials for
these immigrants that want to come here
because their ideology aligns more with
the values of our judeo-christian nation
than kids that were born in this country
so i'm not anti-immigration i want
people to come here but it is not
beneficial to them or to us and it's
definitely not sustainable if we just
like do what la and dc new york do and
say well come on in
and by the way i live in miami right now
which is a hugely immigrant often first
or second generation immigrant city
filled with cubans and venezuelans these
are people who know what their parents
or they fled so they're the most
pro-american people you can possibly
find uh james does this eric adams
situation sort of go to something that
you and i have discussed publicly and
privately for years i've taken the
position for a long time that the good
liberals cannot do anything in the face
of this thing it simply does not work
they try to be nice but they just end up
adding fuel to the fire so in this case
eric adams who is a democrat but they
thought okay he's not a completely
insane democrat he's not the socialist
lunatic bill de blasio he'll do a little
bit better except here we are and it's
obvious that here we are and he doesn't
know how to deal with it and he also
said in there he's not going to stop
them from coming he's just going to ask
for help i don't know who he's asking
but that the good libs they simply
actually at this point are causing the
problem while they're pretending that
they're doing something about it
i completely agree they have absolutely
no tools whatsoever at their disposal to
try to stop any of this we could also
turn and look at how the trans lobby is
just absolutely overriding all of
feminism like feminism doesn't exist
anymore the the the truth is that the
the machine always moves left the
dialectical machine is what it's called
it always moves left and they don't have
any tools to stop it um we do have to
add a little piece of context that i
don't know for sure that it's relevant
but when we look at eric adams when we
look at what you just said with the
immigrants coming in we'll also remember
that the courts just decided that
immigrants can't vote in
new york and so all of a sudden they're
a problem
so what you see is this kind of like
pie in the sky vision for how they can
transform reality to this kind of utopia
that doesn't work in reality that they
can't manage and the good left is or
good lefties or whatever we want to call
them very smart people they're idiots
they
literally have no tools to deal with it
they can't do anything to stop it and
frankly it's largely because they don't
they just frankly don't understand
what's happening in the world around
them they have if you know i tell people
a lot of times you know if there's a
scale of one to ten of how well people
understand the political world around
them my typical smart college educated
master's degree left wing friend is at
about a three
on a good day they just don't know
what's happening in the world around
them so they're useless at best and
causing the problem at worst
they have phds and yet they never
learned you wouldn't want to say heroin
addict taking a dump in a park next to a
lady with a stroller
i don't know they just don't teach that
at yale i thought they did libby what
should people who live insane states
insane cities and i apologize alicia i
know and you're always welcome here uh
what should we be should we waste our
time talking about this nonsense anymore
or should we just let new york city go
let seattle go like stop talking about
it stop thinking about it you guys want
this congratulations we're just washing
our hands
we don't do the country or the world any
favors by destroying our cities
um and i i think that that would be
really a shame to just say we're going
to let new york city go with all of its
great cultural contributions that it's
done over the years i think there's a
chance for new york city i think
the city operates best when it's under
republican leadership even as the state
typically has
democratic leadership um and i think
that new yorkers should be voting
conservative i think that they should be
voting for you know uh people who are
interested in maintaining new york city
instead of watching it run to ruin
kamala harris had been tasked with
dealing with the root causes of
immigration she has done nothing perhaps
eric adams should take his plea to save
new york to her but certainly mayors
across the country should not be held
responsible for the biden
administration's total failure to secure
the border and to make sure that the
people who are being led into this
country are not criminals who are here
to destroy our country instead of be
you know functioning members of society
and it's really a shame too for the
hispanic community which has done so
much for this country and contributed so
much to have people just running across
the border um
completely unchecked when you have so
many people who came here legally or who
earned citizenship um through legal
channels so i think adams should be
perhaps
more outspoken than this he should take
his fight directly to the white house he
should tell them to stop destroying new
york city and miami and all of these
other great places that so many
americans call home right the problem is
the problem is we know we know he's not
going to do that and by the way you know
where this all ends i mean right now
we've got florida and texas busing i
want to i want to tell adams to do it
oh yeah yeah yeah we could we could keep
telling him to do it i don't think he's
going to do it but you know this all
ends this all ends obviously with
florida and texas busting these illegals
that the biden administration allows it
they're going to keep busing them to new
york new york is eventually going to
start busting them out and then we end
up in basically mad max uh fury road
where it's just going to be competing
buses going in different directions all
trying to take each other out uh alicia
let me throw this video quick because
you mentioned uh the u.s volleyball
olympian her name is kim glass uh who
was attacked in downtown l.a so let's
just throw to that real quick this was
in downtown los angeles
daylight right and out of nowhere you
get sucked by a 10-inch bolt
and i i just have to think when when you
think back on that it has to there has
to be some something in your mind that's
saying how
why in the world did that happen
and when you ask yourself that how do
you answer it
you know
i sat with it i was thinking about it in
the ambulance the other victims haven't
been vindicated right every time
someone's being let out on the street
again and again they're doing a
disservice and they're pretty much
saying that
these victims traumas were in vain
and
at this point what's the answer
you know because something everything
that we're doing right now is not
working yeah well there needs to be
amazing
evidence
alicia i'm going to guess that most
people watching this right now uh did
not see that well they don't watch cnn
and msnbc and the rest of it anyway but
i'm going to guess that that didn't make
it to cnn and msnbc i mean a young a
young black woman gets assaulted i mean
those bruises were serious that was a
serious bash to her face i thought we're
supposed to care about this sort of
thing but seemingly only fox cares about
it what's going on here it is
interesting there's there's even been
some stories when i mentioned earlier
all of the mad moms that are saying no
you're not going to mask our kids again
no you're not going to do covet
lockdowns again the largest business
group here in l.a county has told the uh
the county superintendents we're not
doing this again you're choosing
people's livelihoods and lives are at
stake we're not doing this again and
only conservative outlets are covering
it why because it doesn't fit the
mainstream media narrative is that the
government is the best and they're the
end-all be-all god bless her for
speaking up as i mentioned i've had
friends that have been assaulted and
stocked by homeless people i love the
flower market it's my thing but i no
longer take my girls down there because
there are so many encampments that you
can't even street park anymore the
sidewalks and the streets are full and i
feel for these people but people like
the man that attacked her i will not use
his name because he doesn't deserve any
more media headlines he deserves to be
behind bars and i only wish that kim
would go a little further and speak out
for all of the victims and say you know
all the signatures are in i hope gascon
gets recalled there's a runoff between
karen bass and rick caruso it's pretty
obvious which of the two are going to be
a better choice for los angeles so i i
hope that more people see her story and
more people get involved because it's
not just the president that the is the
end all be all if kovid taught us
anything left right and center your
local races matter
and by the way we all know how this game
is played there is simply no doubt that
kim will soon be called alt-right and
everything else for having gone on fox
to discuss being bashed by a homeless
person because of progressive policies
but let's uh let's go to the last
segment here because you guys know i
like to end this
show and especially end the week on a
somewhat positive note and i think
people are just waking up in droves to
this thing it's becoming increasingly
obvious you can even see the media is
having trouble running cover for biden i
think they're done with him anyway
i don't think this cobid thing helps his
case uh but here's video a year ago him
and let's just call this pandering 101.
it's awful hard as well
to get
latinx vaccinated as well why
they're worried that they'll be
vaccinated and deported
libby uh many latino people those tacos
as we refer to them uh they uh love
being called the teen x right and uh
they're all obviously illegal which is
why they would be worried that they
might get booted if they got vaxxed i
mean do they realize their own racism
they do not realize their own racism
they think they're immune to it they
think that when they talk down to
minorities that is actually lifting them
up they think that when they pander to
you know woke ideology and and and say
these kinds of things that they are
actually helping the communities that
they are substantially attacking but
americans are way too smart for this
nonsense um and they were too smart for
it all along and we're you know we're
watching the the chips come in on that
one
speaking of those chips joe biden now at
38 approval and even cnn is covering it
showed his overall job approval rating a
bit earlier here it is again the 38
percent approve 62
disapproved this is a numeric low mark
for the president in cnn polling but
he's been in this low range which is a
big warning sign of course for his party
james do you remember there was an
orange guy i always forget his name he
had crazy hair he was orange
eight mcdonald's um who never hit 38
despite the media always trying to take
him out the media has propped this guy
up and he's at 38 this is this is pretty
extraordinary don't you think
yeah i mean
what's extraordinary is that it's at 38
and not you know like negative 8
or something um it's absolutely
astonishing to me but at least what
we're seeing is
as you said people are waking up in
droves everywhere i go whether i talk to
republicans whether i talk to democrats
people are seeing whether it's with the
grooming of the kids especially the men
the mad moms or the war moms as i like
to call them are getting very upset
people are waking up all over the
country it doesn't matter which issue
people are are now aware that
something's wrong these gas prices and
then we have both uh biden and
you know mayor lenin i mean pete come
out and say the secret uh
transportation secretary people judge
saying that you know oh i'll suck it up
and get an electric car you know we got
to accelerate the contradictions people
are aware that this is not a government
that's working for americans or for
america and
you know libby mentioned uh kamala
harris i started to laugh because her
name was invoked a moment ago she was
tasked with something that's hilarious
on its own because that's not gonna
happen but um
you know
everybody sees this this is just
a clown show that nothing is going to to
happen nothing in this administration is
meant to work for americans and people
are uh i call her vice president red
pills by the way uh people are very
rapidly waking up to the disaster of
this thing and it's the best news ever
um because it's about time that we move
on from this mess
alicia are you worried that the system
always finds a way that despite
all the mad moms despite the polling all
of that stuff that it's like they'll
either bring covid back or they'll
monkey pox us or
they'll make ukraine into a nuclear war
or just like something because everyone
is sort of feeling like wow we're
starting to win polls are showing it but
we're still
three months or you know
four months basically out from an
election i don't know how in that three
or four months they're going to change
the reality for a lot of men and women
in the united states who are just seeing
outrageous costs not only at the pump
but at the grocery store we were just in
michigan for a week and a half for a
family wedding and i told my husband i
was stunned i went to three different
local grocery stores and i always think
wow la cost of living so high guess what
the only two things that were cheaper in
northern michigan were fuel
and michigan fresh cherries everything
else from the meat to the eggs to dairy
everything was the same price that i pay
here in los angeles that is difficult
because the cost of living in la of
course rent and stuff is more expensive
but if you're a minimum wage worker or a
factory worker or a blue collar or even
white-collar worker in a blue state like
michigan who recent polling numbers have
shown biden is doing abysmally after
winning that state democrats have a big
problem and they can't split the switch
overnight alicia you are always welcome
here we could shoot iguanas in my
backyard fry them up they're quiet
tastes like chicken that's what they
keep telling me
uh
all right libby bring us home final
thought on all of this do you feel
confident that the trend that we're
seeing and why we're all kind of feeling
good about this stuff that will make it
to november without them pulling
something nuts
i hope so but i do think that they have
nuts up their sleeve consistently
they're going to try and push this
climate agenda down our throats they
have been promising to do so since the
campaign
um they're going to try and push
electric cars down our throats again
they're going to try and ramp up covet
and make that a whole big thing again dc
students are going to need to get a
vaccine before they can attend school
we're seeing what alicia was mentioning
about california and masking um so you
know and of course they have this
ukraine war that they can really go hard
on if they want to do that so i think
americans have to be aware of the
persistent crisis narrative that the
biden administration is going to keep
trying to push maintain their cool
maintain their glimpse of reality and uh
you know bring it on home and get these
crazy people out of office they have no
business leading the country
alicia james i thank you all right great
seeing you guys i'm going to finish up
for a couple minutes without you
so long
all right so that's right guys so yeah
sunday i will be speaking uh at turning
point student action summit uh president
trump will be there governor ron
desantis will be there james lindsay
will be there uh donald trump jr will be
there ted cruz will be there etc etc a
whole bunch of people i believe maybe
there's some tickets still available i'm
not sure but it's turning point action
summit i'm being told there might be
some tickets available i'm speaking on
sunday morning
and tonight and tomorrow all day uh i am
co-hosting the sunshine summit right
here in fort lauderdale with lisa booth
and this is a big floridian conservative
conference and uh obviously governor
desantis will be there and clay travis
who's a buddy and a friend of the show
and josh hammer who you guys have seen
and carol markowitz and a whole bunch
others so if any of you are in florida
again i'm not totally sure if tickets
are still available but it's the
sunshine summit i'm heading out a little
bit later this afternoon that's my
weekend i hope you have a weekend uh a
little bit off the grid if possible and
i also realized right before i sat down
uh you know we've got baby one due in
just a couple weeks and we're we're now
in that zone we're in that like right
before the end zone situation where it's
like the phone could ring at any moment
at any moment it could be my last
weekend pre-fatherhood and i'm told it
all changes after you're very tired all
the time but it's better in a different
way that's what everyone keeps telling
me it's different but it's better you'll
understand one day something like that
uh so uh i've become
sentimental about my weekends i'm hoping
i get two more weekends after this uh we
shall see uh and then of course as you
guys know next week is our
last week in studio before i go off the
grid
for august uh we are changing up a few
things which i'll announce next week for
what is going to be on the channel uh in
august we are going to put up some other
stuff although i do want everybody to
take a bit of a break from the news and
everything else if you can during august
and i want my team to be able to take a
break and and all of that of course as
well uh let's see okay they're giving me
some notes 8 30 am i will be at sas
giving my big talk and i'm told that
james will be speaking at 9 00 a.m so
you could get reuben and lindsay back to
back if you're in tampa on sunday uh on
that note uh we can do some questions
some comments all right let's throw some
comments from the
community q a from the reuben report
locals community i should say snow baby
says my grandmother used to say when
politics would take a bad turn it would
be the immigrants who would save us they
fled the stuff americans are running to
it's so interesting i mean i really see
that so clearly uh here in miami because
as i said earlier it's such an
international city you know so heavily
cuban especially i mean when we went to
the marlins game last week guys i mean
we were pretty much the only four white
people it was a lot of cubans and it was
all good there was
no but was anyone mean to you guys did
anyone go whitey you whitey with your
baseball no everybody liked it it was
all good but these people come here and
it's either they come here or their
parents or their grandparents and they
fled communism they fled all of the
stuff that these lefties are now
instituting here so it's very refreshing
seeing these people and that's why as
alicia said it's like there's very few
people who are truly anti-immigrant of
course there's a certain set of people
who maybe don't like somebody based on
the color of their skin
of course that exists right but there's
very few people who are just on their
face anti-immigrant what there are
people who want a set of rules right i
mean it's one of the lines that that
orange guy said when he was running for
president which is we either have a
country or we don't you either have
rules or you don't
and the left which seemingly has no
rules and and wants everyone to come
here while at the same time telling us
how horrible everything here is uh then
what happens is you get a situation like
in new york where eric adams is now
going boy we let all these people in and
now we've got problems and he's just
he's literally do you see in that video
he's just kind of turning his head like
and we need help help is anyone out
there sort of like janet yellen like i
hope the economy doesn't crash that's
all they have at the end their policies
are terrible so they call for help but
nobody's on the other line and uh they
have hope but it's usually hope that
ain't gonna come true until people vote
in other people anyway oh paula let's do
paula over here why are these teachers
happy when a kid tells them they're
trans i mean that's a great question and
it's and it's a deeply psychological
answer that i probably could have gone
further with james on but i think it has
to do with these people who's they've
sort of had like a certain amount of
people that are
in western society right now have just
had a certain psychological break when
you no longer think that male and female
is different
uh that you can change your sex
all of these things it's like once
you've done that that's why they're
trying to get to these kids so young if
you can take a six year old who is not
thinking about sex in any way or gender
but start getting them to think about
these things and then tell them actually
your parts have nothing to do with your
reality
what have you then injected into that
kid's mind that then perhaps you could
manipulate for the rest of their lives
what else could you get them to believe
in they could just be a little cog in
your very very twisted game that's why i
said earlier it's like i'm not totally
convinced that all of these people are
groomers and that they are grooming them
purely for sexual
purposes as disgusting as that is and
and
undoubtedly there is some of that right
that it's more what james was referring
to which is that they're grooming them
to be sort of broken confused people who
won't even believe the things that they
can see right in front of them or
perhaps the things that they can see in
the mirror because once you break
someone to that degree especially a
six-year-old man the way you could
manipulate them is probably unimaginable
mark says my wife eva and i have adopted
the approach that we must keep our kids
in homeschool no matter what even if we
have to live in a one-bedroom apartment
in order to pay for it it's that
important
well mark i know you're from the
community and you're you're a fine
father and i'm glad that your kids are
doing well and yeah i think a lot of
parents are on board that uh that being
said i think you know in certain red
states and again this is where florida
really is leading the country um they
are getting woke-ism out of school they
are getting critical race theory out of
school they are teaching financial
literacy
they are teaching basic civics uh you
know stuff that we used to learn you
know i'm an old dude when people like me
used to learn that and say the 80s 86
big year for civics
basic math that's what we were doing
back then uh anyway i hope you all enjoy
the weekend uh get off the machines a
little bit get out there get some fresh
air
go shooting go play some basketball go
swimming go fishing
do you
but don't do it online how about that
but if you do do it online join us at
report.locals.com
see you monday